はい よろしくお願いします
これから今日の話を始まります
あの 今日のテーマは この冒険者はパターンから脱出するということで
あの 元気よく生きるにはリフレッシュが必要ですと
まあ一応このタイトル最初に作られたところで
まあ仏教に何の関係あるのかという疑問もありましたけど
それほどあの内容をできるだけ難しくならないように気を付けてお話をさせていただきます
最初にこのパターンというものの良し悪し何でしょうかと
まあちょっと考えてみましょう
あのパターンという何のこと
後で説明します  なんとなくわかりますからね
仕事などのパターンさえ身につけば
問題なく失敗なく仕事はできる
それぐらいわかってますね
このいろいろパターンがありまして
それがもう自分に自分が慣れてしまっちゃえば
もう仕事はそんなに難しいことはなくなっちゃうんですね
そうすると落ち着くんです
朝仕事に行くのは別に嫌なことじゃないんです
もう結構すぐ慣れてる作業始まりますからね
しかし 決まってる型にはめられていると
ロボット化現象が起きて
人間の人間の性質は薄くなるんです
人間の性質といったら
なんかちょっとややこしい言葉
人間であること 生き物で
人間でね 生の人間であること
それがどんどん減っていくんですね
なのになんで人間の性質って書いたのかというと
やっぱり人間らしく たくさんいろんな持たなくちゃいけない性格いっぱいあるんですよ
そういうものを全部なんかどんどんなくなって
あのパターンの中で動いているロボットになってしまうんですね
だからなんかちょっとどこかででも人間欠けている
人間性に欠けているということになってしまうんですね
また突然変化が起きたら
体も心も困って固まって止まるんですね
毎日毎日ワンパターンで同じルーチンと言いますね
パターンというのは英語だったらね
同じルーチンで と言ったっても
日本語ではパターンと言いますね
で 毎日毎日同じパターンで
生きていて 突然何か起きちゃうと
もう手も足も出なくなっちゃうんですね
こういうことよくあって
私もこのいろいろ このカウンター受付とか
いろんなところで仕事をやってくれる人々がいますから
まあちょっと冗談でからかってみたりはするんです
そちらはもういくらかは用意して
こうなったらこうする
こうなったらこうするというね
まあそのパターンにはめているので
私はもうすぐこのパターン何かとわかりますから
それに関係ないことを聞くんです
聞いた途端 もう頭どうせもうなくなっちゃって
もう本人が私が日本語わからないと思ったりするんです
日本語で喋ってるんですけど
ある人には本当に言いたくなった
あんた方はもう人間じゃないねとかね
だからこの その決まってるお客さんが決まってる質問するならば大丈夫ですよ
ニコニコと暗記している文章で答えるんです
もし決まってることと違ったことを聞いちゃうと
もう どうすることもできなくなるんです
そこっていうのは あの
パターンの仕事をするのは簡単で便利かもしれません
だけど そういう危険なところもあります
逆にパターンを知らない人は何もできないか
何をやっても失敗する
そこでどんなことにしたっても
やり方というものがございますでしょ
それがパターンということなんですね
それが知らないとできるわけないんですね
だから逆にパターン知らないともう何もできないんですよ
あるいはやってみたっても決まって失敗するんですよ
そこで同じ仕事を何回何回も繰り返して失敗する人は
もうパターンを学んでないんですね
大体人間っていうのはそんなもんでしょ
同じ失敗は何回も繰り返しちゃうんですね
仏教でいうのは失敗する流れではなくて
一回で止まれと 失敗はありますよ
いたし失敗したら同じ失敗は二度としない
それならそのパターンを学んだということなんです
どうせ仏教的な社会じゃないんだから
人間っていうのは同じ失敗なら
同じ失敗は何度でも繰り返すという
それがありがたいことじゃないんでしょうね
このバブルはじけて日本がひどい目に遭ったでしょうに
今度も同じことでしょうね
前も何もやらなかったんです
日本の経済状況が良くなるために
責任のある人々は何にもしなかったんです
今度も何にもしないんです
前でやった悪いことがまた繰り返してやろうと思っているんです
前にやって失敗したこと
もう一度やりましょうと
そのそういうことしか頭に浮かばないんですね
だからこれはもう冗談じゃないんですよ
同じ失敗何回も繰り返すっていうことは
どこかでね 石油ストーブでね
もう人が死んで家が火事になったと知ったら
一回の事件で十分でしょ
でも毎年でしょ だから
そういうのはね 全然もう学ばないんですね
これっていうのは人間の
まあそういう人間も結構います
それから他人で管理できない
自分にも自分の管理できない
このパターン知らない人っていうのは管理できないんですよ
あんた 3時半にこういうこういう仕事をしておきなさいと言っても
もうこの決まっている通り動かないんだから
仕事は頼めないし 管理できないし
8時半に集合と言ったってできるわけないんです
だから会社なんかではもうまるっきり成り立たない
もうすごく管理されて
その管理の中で生きて仕事をしないと会社ってのは成り立たないもんですよ
会社も工場もどちらでも
言うことを聞かない人だったら
管理できないし 自分にも自分の管理できないんです
で 勝手な行動で社会に
個人生活も成り立たないんですね
だからパターンにはめられない人は勝手に行動するんです
それでは社会が成り立たない
個人の生活も成り立たない
ですから 結論はパターンというものはあってもなくても困る現象なんです
パターンに見事にはまっていると
なんか人間性を失ってしまって
退屈になっちゃって もうロボットになってしまう
だからパターンだけにはめた人も
結構犯罪を起こしたりも知らない
気づきもしない そういう場合もあるし
ただし パターンにはまっていると仕事は淡々とできるし
社会人として生きていられるし
自分の個人的な人生もそれなりに成立していることもできる
パターンが悪化したこと
とんでもないことになる
ですから 結局はあってもなくても困るということになります
はい  パターンについての良し悪しはまあそういう程度でして
で またテーマはちょっと変えてみます
世界が認める能力といたいたい
よく聞いた聞く言葉ですね
能力っていうことは 能力って何なのか
世間が言う能力は 能力とはパターンを知ることなんですよ
あらゆるパターンを 世の中で何にでもパターンがありまして
それが知ってるならば能力があるんですよ
例えば車が故障する ある人はこの車の中身
どんな風に動くものかどうか
そのシステムパターンを知っているんです
こうしたら まあこういう現象だったら
まあこの中でこれこれ動いてないでしょう
じゃあこうすればいいやと
すぐそこをもう直したりするんですよ
それで私びっくりしました
あんたすごい能力あるんですねとかね
修理のライセンスも何も持ってないのに
ただの素人なのによくできたもんだなとかね
能力者として認めてしまうんですよ
だから能力あるっていうことは
どんなものについても同じことで
そのパターンを知っている
どんな小さなことでもね
部屋の掃除頼まれたところで
さっさととても綺麗にやる
やった人が そのいかに掃除すればうまく
簡単で美しく よく見事にぴったし綺麗になるのかと知っている人
そのパターンを知っているんですね
だからもうすぐあなたにはすごいその能力がありますねとか言われるんです
だから世間で能力 能力と偉そうなことを言うんだけど
実際はこのあらゆるもののパターンを知っておけば
それに対して能力があるということになるんです
能力とはパターンに慣れることです
知っただけでダメです
そのパターンに慣れなくちゃ
スポーツ選手はパターンを理解し
次それに体を慣れるんですね
スポーツ選手っていうのは
その各スポーツに対して能力がある人
才能がある人 はっきり言えばどういうことですかね
その自分が行っているスポーツのパターン
全部まず知っている それからそのパターンに慣れる
毎日 毎日 毎日 毎日 卓球にしたっても
どこでどのように球を打ったら向こうにどんな形で来るのかと
その無数のパターンを知っているんですよ
このプロの世界的に卓球をやっている人々は
あれも 4歳からも始めちゃいますからね
だからもう目に見えない速さで
プロはね 卓球をやってるでしょうに
普通の人にはもう一つも打てないんで
いくら踏ん張ったっても
あまりにも速い で 目に見えないことで打っても
こちら側がもうこちらで送った球が狙っていくんだから
狙った場所に落ちるし
それだったらどこに行くかも知ってるし
そちらに行ったら この人はこういう風に打つでしょう
打ち返すでしょうだろうと
そんなのはもう全部もう肉体で
体で 細胞で知ってるんです
だから目で見える必要もないんです
そこに目に見える 見える速さで球がすぐに戻ってきますけど
もうあれ なんとかのラケットが行ってるんですね
そちらに そういうことでプロだと
才能があるんだと みんなすごいことを言うんです
で そういう人々はあの
野球は卓球は例にしたんですけど
卓球はそうシンプルじゃないでしょうに
あのテーブルのどこに当ててどうやって飛んでくるかっていうよね
そこはいろんな方法がありますよ
飛んでくる角度やら高さやらいろんなものが
あれ 面白いことは自分の方に
で来るんだけど まあもしかするとそれはちょっとオーバーアウト
素人はそれでも自分の方に来たんだから打ってしまったりするんですけど
プロはアウトになると先に知ってるんです
バレーボールの場合でもね
向こう側が来たボールが
それはどう見てもアウトになるので
もう触れます 触ります
その場合はどれほど早くその判断しなくちゃいけないかと判断しないんです
本当は体がそうもう慣れてるんです
で 向こうもプロだから
もうこれは明らかにアウトやと見えるようにボールを送るんですよ
でもアウトにならない
ちゃんとコートの中に落ちるという
知ってます それが だからとにかくタッチするんです
だから試合は随分早く終わりますけど
その中に大変な能力が
驚く能力が機能しています
そこでその能力は何なのかというと
物事のパターン 知ることと慣れることという 2つなんです
別に同時にそれできますけど
一応2つに分けたりした方がよろしいんですね
例えばサッカーについて
評論家たちがしゃべるは
しゃべるは しゃべるは
もう野球なんか試合やったらうるさくて
テレビやえらい専門的分析やらね
バットはあと 0.3 ミリ上げた方がよかった
あれやこれやとかね 打てるかというと全然ダメでしょうね
やっぱりそういう人々はただ頭でっかちで
様々なことは知っている
が 慣れてないんですね
だから評論家になる だから私は 2つに分けたんです
パターン知ることと慣れることという
学ぶとは様々なパターンを理解し
覚えておくこと この学ぶという勉強するという仕事
世の中にあるんですね
子供たちはもうあまり関係あるかどうかもわからないんだけど
学校で世の中にあるいろんな分野のパターンを覚えるんです
その時も理解すること
それから覚えること 覚えたっても理解していなきゃ役に立たない
学校の子供たちにこの実行してみなさいというところは言ってないんですね
まず覚えておきなさいということで
ですから 世間にある学問というものは
パターンの覚えておくことですね
学力テストでどれほど習ったパターンを使用できるかと調べるんです
学力テストで質問が出るんですね
この質問で今まで習ったパターンをこの人思い出してうまく使えるのかと
そこはチェックするんです
だから大体学校のテキストに教科書にあるものは
そのまま質問には出てこないんです
そのまま出て こんなの勉強してないんだよと
子供が困ったら もう能力はないんですね
学校の教科書のものでは質問作らないんです
英語のテストにしても
一生懸命もうややこしいテキスト
学校では勉強しますけど
そこからは文章は出てきませんよ
1つも 新聞記事とかね
何か誰かの本の一部とかを取り出して
そこで読んで理解して分析しなくちゃいけない
そうすると 学校で学んだ英語は使えるのかという
文法やら表現力やらいろんなことを使えるのかということを調べているんですね
だから学力テストっていうのはそういうことなんですね
仕事ができるということも
その分野のパターンに慣れて
それを使用することができるということです
じゃあ仕事ができる  会社なら仕事たくさんありますからね
いろんな種類の その中であの社員には仕事ができるということは
その社員が自分やっている仕事分野でパターン知っているんだということですね
それを使用できる  デパートでね
女の子たちがいて お客さんにいらっしゃいませやらなんだらかんだらとかする
でもお客さんに挨拶して
帰るときはまた挨拶して
ちょっと笑って まあちょっとかっこつけてあげればいいという単純な仕事なんですよ
ちょっと気分の良い雰囲気を作ってあげてくださいと
各店でセールスマンたちがもう待ってるんです
プロの人々は それでデパートに来るお客さんがどのように質問するか
どんな性格のものか 何を聞くか
そこはちょっとわからないんですけど
それ 自分が習ったもので見事に対応していくならば
例えば何かしらのものがあるのかと聞いちゃうと
この人知らない もしかすると
あ すいません それ知りませんけど
言っちゃうと最悪なんですよ
そこで決して知らないと言ってはならないということがあるんです
知らないと言ってはならないんだったら
知らないんだからどうしましょうかと
仕事を下手な人はそこで困って
困ってと えーと どうしようかねとかね
誰か他の人を呼んだりとか
その人の仕事の邪魔して
それと後でね 反省すると
こいつはもうダメやと
私は忙しいなのに いつでも私を呼びますよと
何かあったらなんとかならないんですか？と言われる羽目になる
そこで仕事できる人なら知らないこと
ああ そうですね  それはあの
受付で あの 案内所でね
そう あの情報ありますから
そこで聞いてみましょう
じゃあ一緒に行きましょうと
すごい知ったかぶりをして
あ それは案内所で全部ありますから
お客さん探す品物はね
もう じゃあ一緒に行って調べましょう
それでお客さんが気分がいいんですよ
このあんた知らないでしょって
その気分に気にさえもならないんです
なんかすごい すごい精密に
このデパートはね 物事をやってるんだと
だから自分探したい品物はちゃんともうカタログにあるかないか
今調べてるところやと
で 気分が良くなるんです
私は電気製品を売っている店にしか行かないんですけど
時々今は行かないんですけど
もう何年も行ってないんですけど
前はいろんなくだらないちょこちょこったのことはね
これはどうですか？値段はどうですかとかね
別なメーカーで作ってないんですかとかね
これってちょっとこの値段は品物のちょっと合わないでしょうと言われて
まあそういえばそうです
別なないんでしょうかと言ったら
まあ知らないんですね
知らないことははっきりわかるんですね
それは男性相手だからどうったことはないんですけど
だからちょっと待ってくださいって
いろんなところで資料を出して
あれこれとか カタログを出して調べて
調べて データを比較して
コンピューターに入れてみて
あ 1個だけはありますよと
でもそれはまあ どこにも取り扱ってないんだから
メーカーさんに注文出さなくちゃいけないんだとかね
やっぱりそこまで調べてはくれたりはする
まあ私はその場合はね
やっぱりこういう時は知らないということを知ってますけど
しかし 元気で頑張って対応はするね
そういうことで仕事ができる人という看板はつけられます
だから仕事をできるっていうことは
このパターン知っていて
そのパターンを覚えているんじゃなくて使用する
応用する だから運転できるっていうことは
教習所で満点取ったことじゃないんです
それで免許試験でも満点だと運転できる
違います 本当にすごい腕の運転手さんっていうのは道路でなんですよ
道路でどのように 車を運転するのかと
当然教習所で学んだことをまたテキストで学んだ
高速な 何でしたっけ？いろいろルールありますからね
そういうものはまあ先生たちがそんなことを思い出したり
十の一番目とか 誰も覚えてない
何番目とかね あるいは一方通行の場合はこういうことである
それは項目リストに何番目ですかって聞いたら
知らない そんなこと知らなくてもよく知っている
プロなら看板なくても
あの道は一方通行だと
もう感じで知ってるんです
だからパターンの使用する能力は仕事できる能力なんです
例えば音楽っていうのは何ですかね
音のパターンなんですよ
心地よいパターンを並べることが創作ですね
音楽を創作するってどうったことない
新しいものを作ってるわけじゃないんです
作れないんです 新しい音楽は
今までかつてなかった音を作ったっても
誰も音楽だと思わないんです
だから 私たちには耳の心地よい音のパターンがあるんです
音楽を学ぶ人は その耳に心地よい音のパターンを知っていて
それの練習して いくつかのパターンを組み合わせる
それは創作ということになるんです
画家だったらどうですかね
同じこと 画家もパターンを学んで練習するんです
家事であってもパターンで決まり
じゃあ家事は同じこと
全部パターン パターンを理解できない人に頭が悪いと言うんです
世の中 頭が悪い人やってる
パターンを理解できない
覚えられない 使用できないということなんです
例えば 覚えておいたっても使用できない場合は頭が悪いというんです
あんた頭だけやと役に立ちませんと
それは本人の自覚でもあります
この頭が悪いということは
あまり言わなくたっても
面白いことは大体確実に知ってます
だって自分がパターン理解してないんだから
どうにもならんですよ
何もできないんですね
パターンを頭で知っていても使えない
なれない人は能力がないという枠に入ります
そこで頭が悪いという単語の意味と能力がないという単語の意味が違います
仏教を学ぶと同時に この日本語も覚えてください
皆様方は意味を気をつけないと喋るでしょ？
で 私はこのものすごいシンプルな日本語使ってますけど
ほぼ中学程度の日本語使ってます
中学まあ低年高年でもないんです
しかし この単語の意味はすごく気をつけていますけど
そこにみんなあまり鈍感で理解しなかったら
私は何言ってるかわからなくなるんです
だから 私の単語能力では
頭が悪いということは
前言ってこのパターンの理解できない
能力がないということは
パターンの理解を覚えることはできるんだけど
使用できない 応用できない
その時は手足が止まっちゃうんですね
それで能力がないということです
例えば大学で文学を習った人々は結構いますよ
しかし 文学作品書ける人っていうのはすごく少ない
芸大で映画を映画じゃなくて画家になろうと
そういう もうものすごく苦労して苦労して卒業もしますけど
絵は描けますけど 画家にはなれませんね
どこかで学校でもう先生になるだけ
だからその場合は頭が悪いんじゃなくて
能力がないなんです 音楽を学ぶ学んで卒業する人っていうのはいくらでもいますよ
でも音楽家にはなれないんですね
その場合は能力がないって
能力っていうのは この学んだものをいかに使えるのかっていうことです
あ 才能 パターンの組み合わせができる人は才能がある
応用できるならば能力がある
応用するだけじゃなくて
自分でもこのパターン組み合わせるんです
組み合わせると あ すごい才能があると
例えばヨーロッパに行って
絵を描くことをとことん学んで
ある特定の学派にいろんなところにあって
ずっと長い間人生かけてそれ学んで
それから日本に来て 日本の伝統的な絵の描き塾とかいろいろありますからね
その描き方を学んだりして
まるっきり正反対のもの
そうすると全く分野が
もうすごい正反対だからね
役にも立たない その人はその西洋の絵も描かないで
日本の伝統的な絵も描けないで
ある日突然 全くもう世の中でなかったものを描いちゃうんです
それでみんなびっくりして
あ 天才だ 天才だと言うんです
なんですごいと言うんですかと
その人は今まで学んだパターンの何か組み立てたんですね
組み合わせちゃったんです
それはなかなかわからない
どこで何が組み合わせたかと
それで私たちから見れば
もう天才ですね だからベートーヴェンも天才なんです
普段人が考えないパターンの組み合わせをする人は天才ですね
はい それはこの言葉の定義です
はい それで一つのセクションが終わります